cinéma avec depardieu père et fils
réunis pour la première fois un
affrontement sur grand écran
pour m tempère une histoire de relations
douloureuses voir tourmenté dans
laquelle se retrouve comme dans un
miroir guillaume et gérard depardieu un
dialogue parfois difficiles mais
nécessaires de la fiction à la réalité
parce qu'elle deschamps diane richards
est ce que tu aimes les enfants ça
recommence
je vais pas me répondre
et toi tu défense joue un père et un
fils qui se déchire les aux écrivains
célèbres la personnalité écrasante paul
jeune homme tourmenté en quête d'amour
en écrivant cette histoire jacob berger
voulez parler de son père en la jouant
les deux par dieu lui apporte un peu de
leur douleur
un peu de ces conflits dont la presse
s'est parfois fait l'écho c'est
d'ailleurs guillaume qui a entraîné son
père dans l' aventure écoutez je
suffisamment pleurait avec sa j'avais
envie de me marrer avec ça est ce que
paul dit à leo ou fait à léo des choses
que vous auriez aimé dire à gérard
offert à gérard du fait d'une autre
manière j'ai fait d'une autre manière
qu'un personnage mais j'ai fait pire g
mais ça ça vous regarde que moi c'est
normal dans le sang le fils kidnappe le
père pour le forcer à l'écouté une
situation tragique comique dans laquelle
vont ressurgir des années de frustration
et 28 ans lyon ça fait 250 mineurs que
je suis en jupe à 10 ans passer de 3
avec moi non aujourd'hui pendant ce que
vous aux enfants peuvent vous avoir
reproché qu'on est bien entendu mais moi
j'ai toujours compris le drame c'est que
j'ai compris le fait mais simplement
peut pas changer les rayures du zèbre
alors je m'applique comme je m'applique
toujours mais que autant une femme née
mer autant un homme devient père donc
c'est vrai j'étais père très jeune et je
je me suis bien amusée je pense que je
les ai aussi bien amusé le temps est là
heureusement pour ceux qui qui ont la
sagesse et l'intelligence de pouvoir
attendre c'est la générosité sur ce ce
moment où les choses deviennent plus
simples et fluides ou la paix arrive
aime ton père raconte ainsi par petites
touches épuré l'histoire de les faire et
de tous les fils qui sait qu'il est
censé beaucoup